hey everyone if you're like me you came
out of season eights American Horror
Story apocalypse a little bit
underwhelmed with the ending now before
you get all up in arms and immediately
dislike this video I want to clarify
that I really enjoyed this season in
fact I thought it was one of the
strongest ones since season two or three
and I did think the ending was good just
not great and this season deserved a
great ending why because since episode 4
unlike some of the other aegis seasons
we know where the main storyline is
headed the witches need to stop Michael
from ending the world
it's simple effective and promises an
eventual confrontation between these two
magical powers I'm in now this video is
a bit different than my normal
breakdowns which by the way if you
haven't seen do check them out hashtag
shameless self plug so bear with me as I
ramble on and try to edit this together
I'll be splitting this video into two
sections the first half an analysis of
why the current ending left a lackluster
taste in my mouth and the second will be
how I would have changed the ending and
yes Ryan Murphy I am available to write
on season 9 hashtag things story for
season 9 so if you just want to hear
that I've left a link to the time jump
below my intention is not to [ __ ] on the
ending again I think it was a good one
so let's just start this [ __ ] sandwich
off with what the current ending did
write one a cleared up event set up
throughout the season like why Coco is a
[ __ ] to Malory how she met Brock how
Cordelia myrtle and Madison survived the
blast the identity spell and it even
gave Constance a proper fu to Michael
number two although not story related
the practical effects were fantastic
Mead blowing up dine is machete to the
neck and Madison's head exploding were
excellently crafted and I thought well
directed those points aside I found the
endings impact on the overall narrative
could have been much more powerful both
emotionally and plot wise so I've
outlined three ways the current ending
didn't live up to those expectations
number one
the build-up it isn't until episode four
that we really know what the season is
about episode 1 deals with the
apocalypse itself and orienting
ourselves with outpost 3 while episodes
two and three are mainly about the
outpost inhabitants battling it out to
see who deserves a place and sanctuary
but with the return of Cordelia and the
lifting of the identity spell we get a
sense of what this season is a
Michael cause the apocalypse and it's up
to the witches to stop it
this becomes the driving force of the
season fuelling episodes four to ten and
promising an epic battle between Michael
and the witches an epic battle that we
don't really get now it's true that
Michael does battle the witches to some
extent he takes on Madison Marie cocoa
and Cordelia but because his powers so
vastly overpowered to them it's like
watching an ant try to take on a
magnifying glass he has super healing
powers and simply explodes Madison's
head rips out Murray's heart snaps
Coco's neck and Cordelia who I thought
would at least put up some sort of fight
before sacrificing herself doesn't I
wouldn't even classify this as a battle
it was a one-sided massacre but I would
have forgiven all that if it's somehow
granted Mallory powers that would make
her a suitable foe for Michael but
instead she goes back in time to kill a
young Michael who is considerably less
powerful than her so much so that he
dies by the most mundane way possible a
car the spawn of Satan and bringer of
the apocalypse dies to a Range Rover
I found this incredibly anti climactic
considering we spent the last seven
episodes building up to this moment only
for him to get defeated by a 4x4 there's
not even a magical component to his
death either
now I'm not expecting some Voldemort
Harry Potter type [ __ ] but what I was
expecting was something something to
make a season centered around Satan and
which is worth while my second point is
that the ending made it so that nothing
mattered we spent ten episodes dealing
with the apocalypse
then finally prevent it from happening
only to find out it's gonna happen
anyway because a new spawn of Satan has
emerged of course I'm referring to Tim
and Emily's demon child whose evilness
manifests the same way Michaels first
did by killing a babysitter
to me this was like a slap in the face
you mean we watched all these episodes
rooting for the witches to win only to
find out it's gonna happen anyway it
puts the Fu in futility see what I did
there okay I'll shut up but more
importantly are the unintended
consequences of resetting the timeline
malory glosses over one of them briefly
in her epilogue stating that because the
timeline was reset Cordelia never had to
bring Myrtle back from the dead so sucks
to be Myrtle but there were a bunch of
other examples like this
remember how Tate and violet got back
together not going to
Peppin remember Moira being set free
from the house to be with her mother not
gonna happen
Marie Laveau set free from Papa Legba
not gonna happen
hey at least nan still gets to be with
daddy finally there's the matter of Tim
and Emily who I felt were created for
the sole purpose of having this ending
I'm always of the mind that character
should come first and the story services
character not the other way around and
because we didn't care about Tim or
Emily remember we haven't seen them for
seven episodes the shock of them having
a demon child isn't as crazy as if this
were to happen to characters we cared
about now you're probably wondering all
right think story you've just fart
Jacuzzi doll over this ending how would
you change it well now that you asked
the way I approach this and the question
I asked myself is what is the most
emotionally powerful ending while also
making it cool as [ __ ] after all this is
a show about Satan and witches we got to
throw some cool [ __ ] in there now keep
in mind I just spent a few hours
thinking about this not months in a
writers room so cut me a little slack
what if Malory wasn't a witch kind of
like how Michael wasn't really a warlock
of course it will be revealed as a
cliffhanger in episode 9 her real origin
she's the embodiment of Michael not
spawn of Satan Michael God's first
Archangel Michael whose powers include
wait for it chrono Kinesis the ability
to manipulate time this would explain
how her powers are significantly more
powerful than the witches just like how
Michaels were significantly more
powerful than the warlocks this provides
a foil to Michael the good to the evil
the yin to the yang one of the things I
found lacking in a season dedicated to
Satan was the utter lack or mention of
heaven or angels in episode 8 we briefly
get under where angel but that's as far
as we go where's God in all this surely
he doesn't want the spawn of Satan
taking over right so the witches can
still battle Michael and hold them off
to give Mallory enough time but it's
only when Cordelia kills herself can an
angel manifest her powers in her how you
say believe it or not angels and witches
have a history some witch practitioners
believe heavenly entities like angels
are brought to earth in order to help
our mortal Souls ascend imagine the
angel Mallory infused with the spirit of
Cordelia and the other witches finally
strong enough to take Michael on now
Mallory would be able to implement her
chrono Kinesis or as the witches call it
tempest infinitum but
just as she's about to travel Michael
storms in and gets teleported back in
time with her and where do they get
teleported to murder house and murder
house makes perfect sense it's built on
a gateway to hell and has all the
characters we know and love from season
one now Mallory will still need to kill
young Michael but this time she's got
the spawn of Satan clothes on her tail
not to mention the ghost of murder house
getting in her way
some of them would probably help Michael
and some would want to help Mallory
which allows for some cool scenes in
action here eventually what would happen
is Mallory would prevail and Murder
House would be destroyed releasing all
the ghosts from their ghostly prison and
putting their Souls at rest it would be
a fitting end to seasons 1 3 & 9 all in
one swoop giving the season one
characters closure the witches would be
seen as heroes to us the viewers also
still alive in this timeline and a
season 9 ending with more magic and
action that warrants what the previous
episodes promised us I also think it
would just be emotionally powerful to
see the souls of Vivian and Ben Harmon
ascend with their child who died of
birth Constance reunited with her
beloved daughter Adelaide and Moira with
her mother
all thanks to Mallory the Archangel and
a feeder of the spawn of Satan the
apocalypse has been reverted and the
others have been saved so what do you
guys think what are your theories what
did you want to see in the ending should
I have just gone with hot Satan wins and
REE populates the earth with hot Satan
babies let me know in the comments below
and if you liked this video give it a
thumbs up and subscribe until next time
remember daddy loves you very much